hi guys I'm Rahul from simple on and
today I'm going to tell you how you can
become a machine learning engineer but
before we begin let me tell you what a
machine learning engineer actually does
a machine learning engineer creates and
maintains machine learning solutions to
solve business problems they constantly
tweak an optimize the solutions for
maximum performance and scalability they
solve business problems like reducing
customer churn running targeted
marketing campaigns and improving
product experience they also help with
predicting whether a particular
hypotheses will be profitable in the
future they contribute to cutting-edge
research in AI and machine learning now
before you can start off on your journey
to becoming a machine learning engineer
there's a certain number of steps that
you need to follow on this learning path
your first step is to improve your math
skills
mathematics plays a very important role
in helping you understand how machine
learning and its algorithms work among
the many concepts that you need to
understand three of the most important
ones are probability and statistics
linear algebra and calculus now let's
have a detail look at probability and
statistics firstly you have the Bayes
theorem this is used in the names base
algorithm to help categorize your data
then we have probability distribution
this helps you determine how frequently
a particular event will take place for
example you can determine what your
premium for your insurance will be based
on the probability distribution of
expenditure pertaining to insurance
claims you must also learn how sampling
and hypothesis testing works now let's
look at linear algebra now linear
algebra has two main concepts matrices
and vectors they both use widely in
machine learning
now matrices are used for image
recognition where the entire image that
you're using is already in the form of
metrics you need to be able to work with
matrices perform simple operations like
addition subtraction multiplication
inverse transpose and so on
now the recommender systems that you see
in applications like Netflix or Amazon
actually work on vectors this vector is
the customer behavior vectors and they
use distance measures now let's have a
closer look at calculus you have
differential calculus and integral
calculus now these help in determining
the probability of events for example in
finding the posterior probability in an
F based model
in your next step to becoming a machine
learning engineer you need to develop
good programming skills and let me tell
you there are a huge number of options
from which you can choose despite them
to see the c-sharp this Java and so much
more now here's a graph of the job
postings from 2014 to 2017 and you can
see that there are two languages that
dominate since 2015
peyten and R now these are one of the
most wanted languages when it comes to
machine learning engineers these are
closely followed by JavaScript and C
hence we would like to recommend that
you learn Python on R as they're the
best option when it comes to coding in
machine learning algorithms so here are
a few things that you need to know about
Python and arc Python is an
object-oriented language which means
their main emphasis is on the object R
is a functional language which means
their emphasis is on creating and
manipulating functions bison relies on
its many packages and are slightly
faster than Python because it has
inbuilt packages now python is generic
and is suitable if you need to integrate
it with any other software R works a
little more closer with statistical
analysis your next step is to get
yourself some data engineering skills
now these skills are important as they
help you analyze and process your data
as soon as you get it now there are
three major steps when it comes to data
engineering firstly this data
pre-processing now these refer to all
the steps that you need to perform
before data can be processed by the
machine learning algorithm you have
cleaning parsing correcting and
consolidating the data then you have ETL
or extract transform and load you need
to know how data can be extracted from
the internet or a local server you need
to know how to transform the data for
example not all formats of data would be
accepted by the program so you need to
convert the data into a format that is
accepted by the program then you need to
know how the data is loaded into your
program the final step is to have
knowledge about database management
software's or DBMS you need to be
well-versed with MySQL the Oracle
database and no SQL your next step is to
learn machine learning algorithms now
among all the machine learning
algorithms that you can see on screen
you can divide them into two different
categories
once that fall under supervised machine
learning and the others that for
unsupervised machine learning even after
such a division you can further
subdivide them into classification and
regression algorithms now all algorithms
accept linear regression fall under the
category of classification which is used
to determine whether a particular data
falls into a particular category on the
other hand you have linear regression
that falls under regression algorithms
this is used to predict a particular
value then you have k-means clustering
and hierarchical clustering now these
fall in the category of clustering this
is used to group data into clusters
based on certain similar attributes then
you have the Apriori algorithm that
falls under the concept of Association
Association is used to determine
patterns of association among variables
in large data sets so now that you know
about these algorithms let me tell you
where you can learn about them let's
take a look at a simple LAN channel and
let's go to playlists and on this we
have a dedicated set of playlists that
talk about machine learning
here you have videos on machine learning
how machine learning is different from
deep learning and artificial
intelligence machine learning with
Python k-means clustering decision trees
and so on if you want to learn more you
could also go through some deep learning
algorithms like convolutional neural
networks recurrent neural networks long
short term memory networks and so on in
fact we have a detailed playlist that
talks about the concepts of deep
learning
here you can find videos on what is deep
learning tensorflow
what is a neural network convolutional
neural networks and recurrent neural
networks now after you master these
algorithms you need to learn how you can
select the right algorithm for your
problem then you need to create a good
model with one or more algorithms after
which you need to keep tweaking and
optimizing the model so that you can get
the maximum accuracy for further reading
you can go through github where there's
more than 21,000 repositories under
machine learning you can also recreate
published research papers adding your
experience of working with machine
learning and now for your last step
learning machine learning frameworks
machine learning frameworks help make
the lives of developers as well as users
a whole lot easier
they help remove the complex part of
machine learning and make it available
for everyone who wants to use it be it
developers or other users now let's look
at the widely used machine learning
frameworks this tensorflow Theano torch
scikit-learn
and so on now let's look at some of them
in detail first let's look at tensor
flow tensor flow is the most widely used
machine learning framework it's used for
machine learning as well as deep
learning now it's an open source
software library which performs
numerical computations
which is done with the help of data flow
graphs google translate is one of the
most popular use cases of tensor flow
now let's look at Thea no Thea no helps
you define optimize and evaluate
mathematical expressions it was
developed in the University of Montreal
Hasani blocks and key rows are its most
popular libraries now let's look at
SPARC ml library now this is Apache
sparks machine learning component it
also provides libraries for machine
learning which are built on top of rdd's
or resilient distributed datasets
it's very good at providing I trade of
computation and provides very high
algorithmic performance now let's look
at scikit-learn cyclone is able to
provide a huge range of supervised as
well as unsupervised algorithms for
machine learning it is built on existing
libraries like numpy Syfy and matplotlib
scikit-learn actually started off as a
google Summer of Code project and now
has 23,000 github commits and that's it
congratulations you know machine
learning engineer now let's look at the
joy
opportunities in machine learning now if
you have a look at this graph it kind of
speaks for itself
before 2015 machine learning was much
less popular than big data and cloud
computing but all of that suddenly
changed and right now a machine learning
engineer earns around one hundred and
fourteen thousand dollars per annum and
this is a clear indication that
organizations are ready to invest
heavily in people who are skilled in the
concepts of machine learning you can
also make the learning process easier by
using simply learns machine learning
certification
simply launched machine learning
certification course provides 36 hours
of instructor-led training provides 25
plus hands-on exercises gives you
practical applications of 15 plus
machine learning algorithms and helps
you master the concepts of supervised
and unsupervised learning
it also introduces you to artificial
intelligence tells you the techniques of
machine learning data processing
regression classification and so much
more
so if you want to take your first step
to getting certified and getting ahead
click on the top right corner
immediately and with that we've reached
the end of another video I hope you guys
found this informative and helpful thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simply learn hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos turner up and get
certified click here